uh you know i i was um
gosh months ago months ago
was maybe one of a few people who warned
of
uh civil war if we continue down the
path
that we are on and i think that
what we are seeing now with this
divisiveness that
that exists very much online
uh now being translated into action
further points in that direction unless
we as a country do something about it
joining me today is an army veteran a
former democratic u.s
presidential candidate and now former
congresswoman
tulsi gabbard welcome back to the reuben
report
hey good to see you dave always so
there's obviously a ton to talk about
here and a lot of stuff happening right
now
as we tape this but first off do i do i
have to refer to you as
former congresswoman do you keep being
called congresswoman forever
how does that work like when you're when
you're mayor they always call you mr
mayor or mr president
are you congresswoman tulsi forever even
though you've stepped away
i think so but i i don't know the answer
to that my staff uh
former staff asked me that yesterday i
was like you know what i actually don't
know
the answer to that but uh tulsi
is always great tell us your work okay
so
look we're taping this right now as the
capital
is literally being stormed i mean that
is happening right now i know you were
seeing it right before we started just
as i was
um i wasn't planning on starting here
but
what do you make of what's going on
right now
i mean it's heartbreaking to see this
happening at our nation's capital
but it is also indicative this is a
symptom of of much
deeper issues and and challenges that
have been stewing
for a long time and and a lot especially
as of late over this last year
you know where this this conflict
culture that we have seen growing in our
society whether it's online and now it's
being
um embodied or actioned
offline uh it it results in something
like this and so
so you've got to look at uh what's
driving this what's fueling it
you can look at politicians uh political
leaders who are more interested in
uh fueling and and um
uh yeah fueling divisiveness riling
people up for their own
personal or political benefit you see
the media doing the same thing for
ratings
uh you see big tech these big tech
monopolies and facebook using their
algorithms and social media
to continue to push and push and and put
fuel on the flames of this divisiveness
well
you see what is happening here today at
the united states capital before our
very eyes is the manifestation of that
that is
the symptom of these deeper problems and
from a leadership perspective i think
this is where
you've got to look to the kind of
leadership
we need but don't have in this country
right now which is leadership that puts
the well-being of the people and country
before themselves before political power
before their
their their selfish ambition are you
kind of shocked as someone that
that was in the government that just not
only our leadership in terms of
government
but our leadership sort of across the
board our academic leadership
our intellectual leadership you know
there's podcasters and
stuff like that but that we don't have
sort of like
a trusted group of people anymore that
kind of bring us together across the
board
it almost just simply doesn't exist
anymore
i think that's right and i think that
it's become such a segmented thing where
you have
whether it's uh political leadership
those in the media or those in new media
or whatever it is you have these
these quote unquote influencers that
are only speaking to their segment of
people who agree with them or believe
the same things that they believe
and uh and there's no exposure real
civil discourse or dialogue to people
who might have different views different
opinions different beliefs different
political
positions and and i think it's it's not
only not not a good thing for
our country but it i think also
contributes especially when you're using
this divisive rhetoric
and language that can help uh fuel
those who then get riled up and say oh
actually you know what i'm gonna go take
action on this because those people
they are my enemy yeah that's the
dangerous thing
so does this what's happening right now
and then we'll move on to some other
stuff does it sort of feel like this was
inevitable
in a weird way like once i started
seeing it this morning
it was just kind of like oh yeah of
course this is exactly what was going to
happen
and in a weird way it's almost like we
all deserve it for being part of it
or something like that well you know i
i was um gosh
months ago months ago was maybe one of a
few people who warned of
a civil war if we continue down the path
that we are on and i think that
what we are seeing now with this
divisiveness that
that exists very much online
uh now being translated into action
further points in that direction unless
we as a country do something about it we
as the american people
we the as leaders in this country unless
we
shift course and and start uh
leading for the interests of the public
the american people
servant leadership leaders who are in
positions of power whether they're
elected or not elected saying i am here
to serve
this country and the american people not
my party
uh not my political interest not my
political ambition or or selfish
money whatever whatever that selfish
driver may be
we need servant leaders in place leading
with what we in hawaii call aloha you
and i have talked about this before
aloha
is saying hey i respect you i open my
heart and
and i love you as a fellow person as
a as a child of god as a fellow american
and whether we agree or disagree on
different issues whether we come from
different backgrounds or not
um we've got to be able to come together
on this shared common ground and work
for the the betterment and the
well-being
of the country what do you think
i was just going to say one last note on
on the danger of
of what we are seeing playing out today
is uh
this normalization of violence where
violence
uh and and uh you know a lot of the
riots that we've seen over the last year
occurring that violence is
somehow okay if it aligns with
your view of what these people are
quote-unquote fighting for and that's
that's a very dangerous thing because
when i say leading with aloha i don't
mean just okay we're just going to sit
back and not
do anything leading with aloha means
standing up and fighting for
what is right but doing so within the
construct of
of the institutions that we have in this
country for example if you
are concerned about um
the the legitimacy and the integrity of
our elections
take action to do something i introduced
a bill called the securing america's
election act
that if our country's leaders had passed
would have prevented a lot of the the
angst that people are feeling and seeing
right now with this election saying that
you have to have a paper
trail you have to have an auditable
paper backup for any electronic system
so that there's no doubt or question in
mind if
there has been a hack attempt or some
attempt to manipulate
our votes as voters if all of these
people in congress democrat and
republican
had taken that issue seriously and
passed that legislation those who are
now saying hey we have to stand up for
the entire why did you do something
about it before
you we do need to stand up and fight for
the well-being of this country
stand up for our constitution uphold it
but we need to do it in a way that is
constructive and within
the um institutions that have been set
up in this
society that is america so i have no
doubt that
probably every single person watching
this right now is agreeing with you and
going okay that all makes sense
i'm on board so tulsi why'd you get out
like you're exactly what we need right
like i i mean i've tweeted it a million
times
if tulsi gabbard was the future of the
democratic party i could honestly
consider myself a
democrat i can't do that anymore i don't
consider myself a republican
but what you just said there i think
most people agree with
yet at the same time you are getting out
so
tell me about that i had to make a
decision dave and i had to make a
decision uh i made this decision last
fall
of of 2019 as i was campaigning for
president
it was uh uh frankly a practical
decision where i could not both run for
re-election to congress and continue
running for president at the same time
and i uh made the decision to run for
president
it was a very serious decision that was
well thought through and i made the
decision that that
to continue that campaign for the
presidency because of the
the grave issues um that i was raising
in that campaign and the kind of change
in leadership that i really believe our
country needs
so um i'm going to continue to to fight
i may not be in congress anymore as of a
few days
ago but i'm going to continue to
advocate for freedom i'm going to
continue to advocate for common sense
solutions in our society and in our
government
and to continue to bring the truth to
the conversations that we as a country
should
be having if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell